not open yet we're closed
come on man all right I'm coming coming
[ __ ] yeah can I help you yeah I'm
looking for my little brother it's by
your Heights a little bit leaner nothing
less gray in the temples
Sam it's good to see you again Nathan
Sam oh all right all right all right
take it easy
oh I thought you I saw you get shot yes
you did
right there Jesus well the doctors that
doctors they patched me up and they
tossed me right back into the cell
even hey I make calls I checked
everywhere everything I heard everything
I found it all confirmed you were dead
Nathan we killed it garden who can say
they wanted to see me rot in that cell
for the rest of my life and I nearly did
he's a samurai and if I had known I I
swear to you I would have come back come
back
I know anything no it's important now
though is that I'm out
hey hey you still with me
it's better
you're not gonna pass out on me at night
night
it just might it's a lot to digest you
know but how did you get out when did
you get out
how'd you even get here find me I wrote
it slow down let me see
I'll hear about you me yes what's to
tell
call some of your contacts tell me some
pretty crazy ass story crazy stories got
shot hanging from a derailed train in
the Himalayas yeah that uh that actually
happened come on where do I start
start with the best part
okay
do you remember the theory that we had
that Sir Francis Drake faked his own
death sure okay he did I found the
coffin
it's a coastal Panama yeah yeah all
right get this okay
I open it up right and there's nobody
but the bottom this is old German you
shouldn't
hey what can I say another lost city
destroyed and we made it out alive
barely
unbelievable
yeah it was
we should have been there
it's literally unbelievable you tell me
you stumble upon yet another
archaeological goldmine and somehow you
managed to walk away with nothing
oh it's the story of my life I guess but
you know I managed to grab a few
trinkets here and there paid off the car
the house engagement ring the engagement
I'm married I can't believe the stories
that's my wife you got to come meet her
tonight dinner at my place you're coming
to dinner I can tell her all about you
Thanks
I'm in a lot of trouble please welcome
from Sony Computer